[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just a quick note about the iPad I've
been enjoying using it for about two and
a half years now both on and off stage
and I think there are a lot of pros and
cons to it
mostly pros first of all I don't have to
carry around a sack of scores which is
huge because they can get quite heavy
especially during travel I also don't
have to worry about printing or getting
a hold of a physical copy of the score
when I need it right away
I also don't have to rely on a page
turner which is great however I have to
use the air turn pedal which is a bit
awkward to use at first but it doesn't
take much to get over that because it's
extremely extremely handy what I like
most though is how I can use it to mark
up my scores I think especially because
I'm a visual person making notes in the
scores with colors and different types
of markings really really helps me
process the music I do a lot of these
markings Evan practising to either help
me to code the score or keep track of
what I'm working on for example I'll
draw in lines to help my mind organize
what's happening rhythmically with
different colors and symbols I also like
using the highlighters to show different
hand positions that I might want to have
a cue for the best part is that you can
save or get rid of your markings as you
want
[Music]
[Music]
yeah to move
[Music]
some virile Aiden there'll be bluebirds
over the White Cliffs of Dover and
remembrance of d-day is 16